oui bonjour federica bonjour j mee
bonjour a tous notre invité ce matin et
vignes erceau présidente de la duhaime
l'association de défense des usagers de
l'eau en martinique alors dans cet
acronyme a dû m
ce qui est important c'est l'association
de deux défenses c'est pas une simple
association d'usagers mais il ya bien le
terme de défense ce bonjour et venir
sous alors votre association existe
depuis 12 ans 2007 c'est ça donc depuis
12 ans à l'aune de ce qui s'est passé
récemment avec cette mobilisation
d'habitants d'usagé de l'eau dans des
quartiers laventinois qui ont protesté
contre à leur goût de trop fréquentes
coupures d'alimentation en eau et
demander des dispositions donc aux
pouvoirs publics pour y remédier à
l'aune de ce qui s'est passé est ce que
votre association la duhaime est partie
prenante de ce type de réclamation par
rapport donc au service public de l'eau
de la distribution de l'eau est en effet
nous sommes partie prenante mais
malheureusement ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le préfet n'a pas compétence
pour s'immiscer dans les conflits
générés par les sociétés il a des
obligations et peut si effectivement le
conflit dérape et peut demander
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
mais il n'a pas le droit de s'immiscer
pleinement dans les conflits générés par
les sociétés donc il peut jouer un rôle
de facilitateur il peut jouer un rôle de
médiateur
mais malheureusement il peut passer mais
c'est pleinement dans ses dents c'est
confus d'accord alors ça c'est le préfet
mais vous même a dû m
dans quelle mesure vous pouvez
intervenir dans ce type de la fleur de
dossiers oui alors nous nous avions
interpellé le préfet déjà c'est par
courrier mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que nous pouvons accompagner
accompagner nous pouvons accompagner les
les usagers mais on ne peut pas non plus
s'immiscer parce que là c'est un
problème qui réside entre au dc et l'asm
dont chacun a une lecture différente
l'asm estime que c'est parce que
audition l'audois 14 millions d'euros
d'ot alors que audi s'ils estiment que
l'asm ferai exprès ferais je dis bien
exprès de mettre des coupures d'eau au
niveau du lamentin et de l'alimentation
lui m'a donc vous les mettez finalement
non pas deux ados mais face à face à ces
deux entités autour d'une table et
qu'ils trouvent des solutions puisque
les usagers ne peuvent pas continuer
comme ça ça repose sur leur simple bonne
volonté ou est ce qu'il y à un moyen ou
un autre de les y pousser un peu
peut-être de pression oui comme je le
disais tout à l'heure
le préfet peut se fait justement essayer
de mettre un petit peu de pression sur
les deux parties un petit peu parti pour
la sortie de crise donc s'il faut que
ces gens là s'asseyent autour d'une
table pour pouvoir trouver des solutions
à votre connaissance ce sont des
situations qui se multiplient ici ou là
en martinique bon l'enlacer derniers
jours c'était au lamentin mais il y à
d'autres zones du territoire d'autres
communes qui sont impactés non non non
on n'a pas connaissance
les peler les vraies problématiques de
l'association rencontres c'est surtout
des factures exorbitantes des gens qui
reçoivent des factures sans relief sans
relève les gens ne relève alors est ce
un indice mais des coupures d'eau pam
mais il n'empêche que on dit que le
réseau mériterait d'être fait parce que
des coupures d'eau bon il y en a dans ce
cas là peut-être par des litiges entre
sociétés mais souvent il ya des
problèmes d'alimentation parce qu'il ya
des pannes des casses des casses
beaucoup d'actrices pour que je voulais
la pose d'affichés de l'état du réseau
oui je voulais profiter de votre antenne
pour été appelé les distributeurs et
leur dire que la liste des fuites sur
les réseaux d'eau potable constitue en
fait une priorité du grenelle de
l'environnement et qu'ils ont obligation
c'est un engagement fort du grenelle ils
ont obligation d'abord d'établir un
dispositif détaillé de l'état des
réseaux les obligations vous dites que
c'est la loi des lamentations c'est une
réglementation ils ont obligation de
d'établir un dispositif détaillé d'abord
de l'état de leurs réseaux de fixer un
objectif de rendement et surtout surtout
de mettre en place un plan d'action pour
réduire les pertes d'eau ça c'est très
important s'est fait chez nous sherlock
holmes et ans
je ne le pense pas et autant ils savent
qu'ils peuvent être pénalisés elle
pénalise
alors vous parliez de factures de
factures litigieuses de la question
aussi du prix de l'eau courante chez
nous d'ailleurs lors d'une récente
interview je vous ai lu vous disiez
qu'il ya un an n'est lésé par rapport à
l'hexagone
ils payent beaucoup plus cher l'eau mais
à près de 30% de plus je crois que d'un
train de cette pensée oui voilà alors en
fait d'après les études que notre
association a pu réaliser et s'avère que
en fait la martinique est un petit
territoire et qui a trop d'intervenants
sur un territoire il ya trop
d'intervenants et que chaque intervenant
a bien sûr un coût de fonctionnement qui
épate libre c'est ses factures là que
c'est il faudrait réduit alors je suis
quand même heureuse parce que la
guadeloupe est en train de mettre en
place une régie unique de l'eau après
plus d'une vingtaine d'années de combat
par monsieur géré mes parents le
président de l'association de défense
des usagers de la guadeloupe et je pense
que les politiques en martinique devrait
en faire autant en inspirer dites moi
alors qu'elle est quel est exactement
l'implication et qu'elle est quelle
action vous mettez en oeuvre
justement dans ces dossiers de factures
litigieuses quand des abonnés des
usagers estime que bon là on les fait
payer des factures
je reprends votre terme astronomiques
vous allez dis quelquefois dans certains
cas dans quelle mesure vous vous
intervenez vous pouvez accompagner
puisque vous avez un agrément on le
rappelle vous annuel association de
défense des usagers de l'eau en
martinique
vous avez un agrément pour porter les
affaires en les dossiers en justice pour
hériter en justice alors dans un premier
temps quand on nous recevons justement
ces doléances
nous intervenons auprès du distributeur
pour qu'il nous explique la raison
justement de cette facturation
maintenant si après avoir tenté une
solution amiable d'un règlement amiable
la sphère n'aboutit pas eh bien on
dépose le dos c'est carrément au
tribunal ce que nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de faire oui et avec des
résultats de l'efficacité parce que oui
j'ai l'impression que c'est un peu le
docteur l'association vous contre des
multinationales
oui mais le plus souvent dans ce cas où
ils ce sont des gens qui n'arrivent même
pas à expliquer à eux mêmes les raisons
de ces factures donc automatiquement
quand ça va au tribunal le juge se
demande comment par exemple monsieur
dupont a pu avoir ce parce que nous
avons un dossier actuellement ou au dc a
fait une facture de 15000 euros
quinze mille euros pour une consommation
de ces 1000 5000 mètres cubes d'eau donc
quand ça oui non ce masri a soumis sa
place rien contre 15000 euros ce qui a
représenté 5 mille mètres cubes d'eau
donc quand un juge reçoit un dossier
comme ça inutile de vous dire qu'il se
fait il ya donc c'est un poème c'est pas
systématiquement le pot de terre contre
le pot de fer
outre la situation contre les grosses
nom générique nationale de l'eau n'ont
généralement ça se passe bien quand nous
avons un dossier avec un distributeur
généralement ça se passe bien mais dans
l'hypothèse où nous n'aboutissons pas
nous allons directement au tribunal mais
je dois dire que généralement ça se
passe très bien avec les distributeurs
et venir ce président de la duègne
l'association de défense des usagers de
l'eau en martinique que vous vous
préoccupez aussi de la qualité de l'eau
potable
chez nous quelle suite parce que vous
aviez fait une requête auprès du préfet
en lui demandant donc des analyses des
arbres pousser les plus poussées voie la
plus fine de la qualité de l'eau à sa
sortie au robinet l'eau que beaucoup
d'entre nous buvons au quotidien alors
je dois dire deux choses la première
c'est effectivement nous avons notre
association nous avons interpellé le
préfet pour qu'il fasse faire des
analyses au robinet parce que les
robinets en amont c'est bien mais quand
il sait quand l'eau arrive chez nous il
faut qu'on sache la qualité de l'eau et
dans un deuxième temps passa sous le
vieux demandé ça en début d'année en
janvier en janvier 2009 lors du réunion
en préfecture
il ya eu du nouveau jeu les gars n'ont
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas eu de
suite mais s'est engagée
alors je souhaite installer enfin russe
est tenté de répondre à votre demande
non il s'est engagé il s'est engagé et
la deuxième chose que je devrais dire
c'est que notre association a déposé une
plainte auprès du procureur pour la
qualité et le prix de l'eau en
martinique alors je dois rajouter
monsieur carlos que nous sommes ici un
mariage elle a été reçue elle est ainsi
enregistrée avec donc oui il y aura
ensuite il se saisir oui c'est ce match
mais c'est dur a reçu ce douar ajouté
monsieur carouge quand même que nous
sommes près de trois cent soixante dix
huit mille quatre cents à boni d'eau en
martinique a menti ni et que dans les
factures d'eau les usagers payent ce
qu'on appelle amélioration du réseau
donc si aujourd'hui on parle de casse on
parle de deux casses ou le réseau c'est
qu'il ya un gros problème mais pourquoi
bien il ya six ans une partie ses cinq
sens sont reversés à l'odéon donc ça
pour ça va peut-être d'ailleurs tout le
monde le sait car oui je paye la droite
de vence amélioration du réseau donc il
faut savoir bien cette somme qui sont
collectés qui sont versés à l'odéon l1
devrait normalement servi à
l'amélioration du réseau eh bien on va
on va conclure et vignard sous alors ne
vous a dû m
vous êtes la présidente est-ce que vous
appuyez là on a cru comprendre puisque
vous poussez les les élus martiniquais à
regarder du côté de la guadeloupe donc
vous appuyez franchement la demande
d'une autorité unique de l'eau ici à
metz reçoit dès la création de
l'association c'est ça a été notre
souhait on a toujours demandé
revendiquer que l'on crée une un truc
unique une régie unique de l'eau parce
que comme je vous disais monsieur car il
ya trop d'intervenants sur le tueur sur
la martinique
et s'il ya des coûts de fonctionnement
qui sont énormes si chaque personne
trans apens ben on verra c'est en paille
arrive et vous vous avez on a beaucoup
parlé d'état évidemment parce que c'est
un service public et que bon voilà
l'état doit beaucoup s'occuper d'eux de
cette affaire de lomé au niveau des élus
locaux des collectivités des communautés
d'agglomération des mères est ce que
vous avez des contacts ont conclu là
dessus est ce que vous avez des contacts
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir finalement l'écoutent l'oreille
plus ou moins attentif de
de nos élus honnêtement non vous allez
nous avons adressé un courrier au préfet
au préfet dans laquelle nous avons nous
lui avons fait part de nos
préoccupations donc maintenant ses
envies de pas bon donc là lui de mai
vous voulez pas saisir jeu par
l'association des maires là c'est mc
quarrie j appuie la création de
l'association nous avons adressé des
courriers à l'association des maires aux
différents maires de la martinique
à ce jour nous n'avons pas eu de retour
de repoussant n'avons pas eu de retour
merci à venir sous d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce récit président de l'advm
l'association de défense des usagers de
l'eau en martinique
bonne journée à vous tous
[Musique]